you had this unbelievable fight scene i
haven't i haven't seen this with daniel
craig yeah yeah yeah crazy no time to
die so crazy talk to me about that uh
and how do you prepare for that how do
you
months of uh like there was this french
uh um
what do you call it core uh fight
choreographer yeah like the the combat
what do you call what stunt crew stunt
crew yeah and they brought me in you
know a few months before i started and i
would go to london and train and we just
worked on the dance of the fight how
long was it was the fight
the fight itself like on screen
i couldn't 45 seconds and it probably
took you how many months to really get
it down not but i i have dance training
and i think it's all dancing weirdly you
know that choreography right um i had it
fast but you know you're just
you're waiting to shoot the thing so you
just go and practice and all your kick
your your fighting and your karate that
you took to it all helped out in this
yeah of course and like how to throw a
punch properly how was daniel craig was
he
tell me about how gentlemen he's a
gentleman he's a great guy he's funny
um i i feel so fortunate to sit across
the table from him and like just get to
know him and like toss jokes around in
between takes and he's a real gentleman
and he he is a great number one you know
have you worked with any bad number ones
yeah you have you won't talk about that
though no it's not worth it it's not
worth it all i can say is all i can say
is like
when someone makes a project about
themselves rather than the project
that's when i know it's bad
it's the the biggest issue because we
all everyone that's standing in the room
agreed to do this project not with
someone's ego so what do you do what do
you do when someone's got an ego
someone's like you know you're like ah
this is about them how do we do you just
what do you do what's your approach
let them do what they got to do
and just worry about yourself worry
about everybody else do you want me to
call you like sir
underbatch i don't get i don't care yeah
sure whatever so benedict cumberbatch
was an no no no no no no no no
no no you didn't work with him did you
no never no no i'm a big fan though